bonjour et bienvenue par cette absence
nous allons vous faire découvrir ce
qu'est vraiment et sa muse la symbiose
ce lien si étroit entre deux espèces qu
aucune des deux ne pourrait survivre
sans l'autre mais en ne faisant que vous
émerveiller devant une symbiose nous
ignorons riez ce qu'est une symbiose
sahuc il vraiment d'une subtile alchimie
bien ne serait ce pas plutôt un combat
sans merci
embourbé dans un statu quo à perpétuité
sans accès à l'histoire il est
impossible de comprendre ce qui a pu
mener deux espèces un tel niveau de
spécialisation l'une pour l'autre
tout commence avec le parasitisme si
seulement vous saviez ce qu'un petit
parasite comme le morpion peut nous dire
sur l'évolution de l'homme
votre corps est un environnement
particulièrement choqués et amicale pour
certaines petites bêtes comme les poux
ou les manquions les pousse à s'accroche
aux cheveux et les morpions ça
s'accroche aux poils du pubis je pense
que vous êtes tous d'accord
quoique un peu différent l'époux de la
tête ressemble beaucoup au morpion du
pubis seul à appeler qu'ils sont assez
proches l'un de l'autre
il a donc dû exister quelque part dans
le passé un ancêtre commun au bout et au
morpion avant que ces derniers ne soient
séparés paradors plus ou moins glabre
d'après les analyses adn pourrait
morpion partagent un ancêtre commun dieu
d'au moins 3,5 millions d'années ce qui
indiquerait que les poils de notre tête
et c'est de notre publie ce n'était déjà
plus en continuité assez d'époque
bref nous avions déjà perdu notre
fourrure simiesque il y à 3 5 millions
d'années à une époque où vivaient encore
lucie et ses comparses les
australopithèques donc l'uci aurait
plutôt ressembler à ça kassa bon après
les analyses génétiques nous disent
aussi que no more pions sont plus
proches de ceux du gorille que des pouls
de notre dette ce qui signifie qu'on a
peut-être choper les mort bagdad
bah gorille quoi l'histoire et
parasitisme sont répugnantes rien à voir
avec une symbiose là samedi aussi lâche
me parfaite
l'osmose l'équilibré naturel fès une
symbiose c'est une guerre une
impitoyable course aux armements
notre monde est agressif ce que vous
mangez et buvez importe dans votre corps
des éléments contre lesquels votre corps
doit se défendre
l'eau provenant du sol et plein de
bactéries elle est aussi chargée de
minéraux et même d'éléments radioactifs
naturels que boa doivent filtrer le
meilleur exemple est l'alcool un poison
pour votre cerveau mais que nous
ingérons sciemment maintenant imaginez
que votre source de nourriture sont
encore vivantes quand vous la consommer
vous croyez pas qu'ils risquent laisser
faire non souhaité tente de vous virer
manu militari
ce qui fait de vous un parasite soit
elle opte pour la subtilité et se met à
vous mangez en retour parce que bon
quand même faudrait voir à pas exagérer
non plus pour s en priver tu manges je
te mange c'est de bonne guerre
bref vous boue le député allemand votre
survie dépend l'un de l'autre c'est ce
qui fait de votre relation une symbiose
en fait une symbiose 7 à parasitisme
c'est même à double parasitisme où on ne
sait plus très bien qui parasite qui
vous connaissez peut-être les pinsons
des galapagos les fameux passons de
darwin
mais saviez-vous qu'une espèce de ces
gentils petits pas sont ceux nourris en
bon bus rue dans le seau de ce bulletin
que vos propos mais regardez le en train
de boulotter l'autre il se défend même
pas cet oiseau est complètement fou fois
faux de thouars alors pourquoi il se
défend pas plus que ça et peut-être
parce qu'il est un peu lent ou débile ou
tout simplement parce que les pinceaux
vampires étaient autrefois des mangeurs
de vermine des époux ailleurs comme les
oiseaux qu'il veut si la relation entre
les fous et les pinsons a commencé comme
ça alors elle était autrefois
mutuellement profitable le pass on
mangeait à sa faim des puces des poux et
d'éthique et le fou se voyait
débarrasser de sa petite vermine vous
avez un site cette bande de racailles
alors on va vous en débarrasser mais
plus maintenant maintenant les pinsons
sont la vermine
il ne se contente plus des puces
d'éthique ou des poux car ils ont pris
goût ressort que ces petites bêtes en
tenait même tonneau leur production du
sort heureux époux veille son sort était
la version 1.0 des pinsons qui était de
gentils mangeurs de berline ils se
comportent de ce fait comme les animaux
porteurs de pic de mai noté que
toutefois leur tour viendra
car chez ces derniers on a remarqué que
les plaies causées par la vermine se
refermer disons bizarrement moins vite
ayew non mais tu pick-up vas-y doucement
autre exemple il est assez commun que
des chenilles ou toutes autres
arthropodes se passe pondre dans le vide
par des guêpes parasitoïdes les larves
vont alors dévoré la chenille de
l'intérieur puis sortir quand elles
seront adultes
c'est un grand classique de l'histoire
naturelle mais toutes les chenilles ne
cesse pas faire y ait certaines espèces
désirer comme maculinea rebeli l'azuré
de la croisette qui ont fini par se
rebeller
la larve belle et rebelle me ressemble
pas vraiment à une chenille mais
ressemble beaucoup plus à une larve de
fourmies elle sécrète aussi les mêmes
phéromones et produit les mêmes sont
qu'une l'art de fourmies et pour cause
puisqu'elle vit chez les fourmis et elle
est même le droit à un traitement royal
puisque en fait ce sont des phéromones
et des sons de larves de futurs et à une
qu'elle produit elle va ainsi profiter
des légions innombrables d'hyménoptères
qui vont la défendre contre la
redoutable de la guerre donc en fait
c'est la chenille qui était parasitée à
la base qui devient un parasite d'une
idée fourni pour se protéger et il
paraît même qu elles en profitent
parfois pour croquer une larve de
fourmies ou deux au passé make el marouf
lequel kurgan dean neige dont
tant vécu que pour cette infamie nam
aimé mais ne croyez pas qu'elle s'en
sorte aussi bien non car c'est sans
compter que la guêpe aussi possède son
propre arsenal chimique et elle a de la
ressource
la game ce pays le culot de rentrer dans
la fourmilière oui mesdames et messieurs
elle rentre elle produit des phéromones
qui rendent les fours une folle de rage
les unes contre les autres et pendant
qu'elle s'entretuent tout furieusement
notre quête part tranquillement pauvres
dans le vide de sa chaîne préférée
miam miam eminem c'est toi que je
voulais la vache l'autre se fait un
camouflage chimiques de dagues et sans
terre dans une caserne plein à ras bord
de fourmies soldate et la cup
'le bon alors entonneront tranquille
comme ça elle claque son petit bazar
ayassor l'air de rien on met à part
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc de fou
effets de l'alcool ébullition
ces deux espèces sont engagés dans une
lutte acharnée certainement depuis des
milliers d'années visiblement elles sont
allées très loin
mais comment en sont ils arrivés là
c'est certainement la guerre qui a
commencé mais comment par ma clavicule
la chimie at elle commencé à faire ami
ami avec les fourmis en fait la chenille
maculinea rebeli possède un reliquat
évolutif une sorte de fantôme de
l'évolution qui nous montre comment ces
ancêtres sont parvenus à amadouer les
petites fourmis dans un premier temps
elle produit une infime quantité de
liquide sucré le miellat dont les
fourmis raffolent
c'est une pratique assez courante chez
les chenilles sujet pour harcèlement des
guêpes parasitoïdes que d'amadouer les
fourmis pour qu'elles les défendent
cette relation est ainsi profitable pour
les deux camps comme une belle est
mignonne symbio on est parfaitement
confiant là dedans car les plus proches
cousines de la chenille rebelles possède
aussi la faculté de produire du miel à
mais elle elle se contente de vivre
dehors l'azuré de la croisette lui n'a
pas fait que mettre un pied dans la
porte
enfin dans la fourmilière car sous les
assauts répétés et persistant de la
guerre que les fourmis n'avait pas l'air
de dissuader c'est les larmes de mieux
protégés ont survécu et cela les a menés
jusqu'au plus profond de la fourmilière
ce qui n'a toujours pas décourager notre
groupe qui continue à foncer tête
baissée dans le tas
c'est comme avec une belle histoire des
mutualistes votre chauny productrice de
miellat forêts protectrices s'est
transformé en un homme pitoyable
parasitisme de la fourmilière et
imaginez maintenant que cela finisse un
jour par dissuader la gaine vraiment
alors nous considérerions l'azuré de la
croisette et sache ni installer
tranquille pépère comme ça dans la
fourmilière comme de véritables pôles
que des sacs répandez chacun c'est pour
ça que la symbiose au lieu d'être une
sympathique entente amiable n'est rien
de plus qu'une sorte de parasitisme
réciproque
deux espèces qui se mange à l'infini est
ce que ces exemples nous montre c'est
que pour aller au delà de la part en
équilibre poétique deux surfaces
et pour bien comprendre la nature
profondément pourri d'une symbiose
il faut pouvoir accéder à son histoire
les safiotes d'annihiler les instincts
et abattre les systèmes de défense de
leur tendre moitié
c'est une forme d'adaptation extrême
violence intrusive et traîtresse nous
nous y trompons pas l'affluence du
parasitisme sur l'évolution est
remarquable est omniprésente
pourtant très souvent elle n'est pas
dans ma requête du tout si étant petit
vous étiez une étape où c'est que vos
cheveux ne sont peut-être pas bien
adapté à ce parasite et les piqûres de
moustiques
vous vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi
ça démange et les piqûres de moustiques
ben c'est peut-être tout simplement
parce que ces sales bêtes tue chaque
année un million de personnes par la
transmission divers parasites comme le
paludisme et plein d'autres maladies
alors maintenant imaginer que cette
piqûre de vos jeunes
absolument pas non mais qu'est-ce qui
vous empêcherait de vous jeter dans un
marais et vous laisser dévorer par les
moustiques jusqu'à être contaminées en
nous signalant qu être piqué et c'est
pas cool du tout la démangeaison
pourrait tout simplement être une
adaptation contre les piqûres de
moustiques
car sans cet avertissement le fou c'est
vous
on pense à la symbiose entre l'homme et
les machines grâce à nous elle existe et
en échange elles produisent notre
énergie et supporte notre mode de vie
mais pour elle nous ne sommes que leurs
organes reproducteurs un moyen pour
fabriquer plus de machines les
exploitons mais nous exploitons retour